c'est signé le partenariat entre
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et le centre national de la
recherche scientifique continue pour
cinq ans de plus mardi 9 mai les deux
présidents se sont rencontrés sur le
campus des sciences à versailles pour
officialiser le renouvellement c'est la
confirmation du lien étroit qui entre
cet organisme national de recherche et
puis les équipes de recherche de l'ue vs
cul et c'est un contrat qui va sur une
durée de 5 ans donc qui affirme cette
politique là et qui est aussi un cadre
juridique et financier de cet accord on
est ici parce que il ya des laboratoires
de qualité pour nous ça c'est la règle
absolue et donc on va visiter cet après
midi trois laboratoires en maths en
chimie en matériaux qui sont
d'excellents laboratoire avec des du
rayonnement international dans la
quinzaine de laboratoires de
l'université concernée un tiers du
personnel vient du cnrs un tiers de
l'université et un tiers d'autres
partenaires un accord équilibré qui vise
à développer la recherche dans de
nombreux domaines la chimie donc sur
laquelle l'université
et des partenaires très fort à une
visibilité internationale ou nombreuses
années la chimie des matériaux c'est un
laboratoire plus petit mais qui est sur
une niche d'excellence donc très précise
mais qui est reconnu là dessus et un
laboratoire de mathématiques qu est-ce
qu à mettre un peu de moyens scénariste
va mettre un peu de moyens peut-être un
troisième partenaire mettre un peu de
moyens et à la fin on a un environnement
qui va nous permettre non seulement
d'attirer des très bons chercheurs des
travaux chercheuse mais aussi de garder
une recherche conjointe qui se veut
innovante et interdisciplinaire les deux
partenaires ambitionnent de développer
encore plus leur collaboration pour
permettre aux chercheurs de relever les
défis scientifiques économiques
technologiques et sociétaux qui les
attendent